I was starting to read the
psychoanalysts and I really got,
I really got interested
in what they had to say,
um,
partly from reading Freud because I was
really interested in his analysis of
family dynamics and have dreams,
but more particularly from reading young.
And one of the things I learned from Yoga,
which really has never ceased to shock me,
was his,
see,
he basically made a point.
And the point was that you're
not master in your own house,
that there are forces that are,
are operating on you at an
unconscious level that determine,
for example,
the direction of your attention.
So for example,
you know how sometimes you'll read
something in to really grip you and then
you'll read something else and you like,
you can't even concentrate on it.
And you might say,
well,
I need to concentrate
on this boring thing,
you know,
cause an exam depends on it or a promotion
and there's just no damn way you're
reading it and your attention
flits all over the place and,
and you know you're
undisciplined and all that,
but,
but then you have this other thing and
it just grips you like this and you
think,
okay,
well what,
what's doing that?
It's not your will.
Because your will would be the thing
that would allow you to concentrate on
whatever you chose to concentrate on.
It's something underneath your will
that's actually directing your attention.
And you could say,
well it's random,
but of course it's not.
It's maybe random if you have a
serious case of schizophrenia.
But,
and,
and I think in some sense that's
actually the definition of schizophrenia.
But it's not random.
If you're a functioning human being,
the thing that grips your attention and
directs it to one place or another is
something that's what's a deep instinct.
It's a manifestation of
what union called the self,
which is a very interesting idea.
So human thought,
it's such a cool idea.
He thought that the mechanism that
directed your attention in the present was
your future self attempting to
manifest itself in the present world.
So you might say,
well you have a potential and that
potential is what you could be in time.
And in order for that
potential to manifest itself,
it has to be palpable in the present.
And the way that instinct for further
develop manifests itself in the present is
by directing your attention towards
things that are likely to increase your
competence and further
your growth right now.
And that's just an unbelievable idea.
You know,
it's like your,
your potential better self
beckoning to you in the present.
Amazing.
And I really can't think of a
better explanation for it than that.
That's a,
that's a really good explanation but a
very frightening one because it means in
some sense that you're,
that something as fundamental as your
attention is more or less controlled by
processes that are so deep that you don't
have a tremendous amount of voluntary
control over them.
Like you can interact with
the forces to some degree,
but you know,
you're not one of those per creatures
that can just tell yourself what to do.
Life would be really easy if
that's what it was like right here.
It's time to go to the
gym three days a week,
two hours a day.
It's like,
you know,
you're superman in two years so you
can eat properly and you know you're,
you're not going to drink too much and
you're not going to take cocaine and all
of these things.
He just tell yourself that and bang,
you quit.
And it's kind of weird
that it isn't that way,
but it's really seriously not that way.